he's moved you welcome to the DS show
I'm excited you're with me I'm a few and
you know what we got so much great
things to talk about a special guest on
the D show back here on the D show my
special guest dr. Akram yes I say that
right
well yeah dr. Ikram Bashir Bashir now
you said Bashir everybody knows my good
friend he's here actually your husband
is here with us dr. Bashir and that's
how he actually recommended I have you
on the show because so many people got
to benefit from I mean you guys from
from the program I've done with him you
guys have authored so many different
books on not only parenting but also on
marriage is that right yes we been
working together on that for quite a
number of years now I I don't remember
when we started but hamdullah we felt
that you know we we our life is going
good and we are able to communicate and
make a happy family for ourselves and
our children and alhamdulillah we
started like giving lectures and that
and then writing books was a next step
to try to spread the knowledge because
everybody deserved to live happily and
we know from allah subhanaw taala in the
quran allah tells us Manami la sala
hanuman the korean i will tell who a
mean fella know he and now hayatun
tayyiba
meaning whoever does good deeds and he
is a believer allah will make him live a
good life so sometimes people lose track
of why their life is not really working
together why a couple are not happy with
each other
and it could be the little things about
understanding each other about being
able to forgive and forget and sometime
strike the balance because sometime many
times the person is
closer to herself or himself than to
their spouse they know what bother them
they know what makes them happy and if
they not communicating well and they
telling the other person their spouse
what they expect from them then it
doesn't work and they don't really like
you know someone might think well he
should know what pleases me or she
should know what pleases me but that
that's not how it works we better learn
to talk more and tell each other about
it
in a calm way not to bottle everything
up and wait until we can take anymore
and then explode is it is it fair to say
it's an art when I opened up the show I
mean the art of dealing with a woman did
you say it's somewhat of an art I agree
I think it's very much a good
description for okay because there there
are some we know that that the women are
emotional creatures right sometimes and
especially at certain stages of a
woman's life some some things happen and
they might handle things differently so
we want to get some advice if the
husband now he's not able to handle
these situations sometimes you know this
the man he just can't you know handle
all these emotions and he just loses it
so uh what advice do you give okay the
advice here is to acknowledge that as
you said the woman is different Allah
made us in to gender for a reason allah
subhanaw taala decided that you know it
would be best for the woman to be
emotional because being emotional
doesn't mean sometimes by the way when
people say the woman is emotional they
mean that it's she is too emotional she
is too irrational but that's not it
being emotional is something that is
needed for a woman and and even for you
know for it's for the benefit of her
husband for the benefit of her children
this is how she's made she she is more
emotional than
the man for sure and for the husband to
know that she is emotional what does
this mean it means that you know
acknowledge this emotion and it's not
hard just if you tell if a husband tells
his wife that you know he's lead say and
instead of ignoring that he doesn't
spend time with her instead of just
thinking okay what's the matter with you
just to say to tell her something like
you know it was I would like to be here
with you but really I needed to do this
or that or this but then decide about a
time when he can be with her acknowledge
her needs the talk about it talk more
because most men as I see it they don't
talk enough with their wife and then the
same time the wife or the woman need to
tell him what pleases hear what she is
expecting from her from him so it's not
like you know everyone assuming that he
should know and and he assumed that what
is upsetting her it's rather that she
need to help him understand the hair and
he need to listen and she needs to
listen they both need to listen to each
other so they can understand better
about each other because although there
is a common area between them how they
are similar in in something they are
different in other things and if that
was not for a wisdom they would have
been a lot of Hanoi tile I would have
created all of us the same
so being emotional here meaning that
this to be acknowledged she's still
rational she still have a mind to think
and she still acknowledge intellectually
things and so on but she is for sure she
needs for her emotion to be acknowledged
much more we're gonna go ahead and
before we get into the to the next
question we take a break come back and
we'll talk some more here with dr. Akram
and you don't want to go anywhere we got
some some great stuff to talk about
we'll be right back
please subscribe to the Biggio follow us
on our official Facebook and Twitter
pages in the links below
please also help support the D show by
making a donation in the link below back
here on the D show now let me know for
our audience in these times when you
know and specifically now the things I
want to I want to focus on are some of
the the challenging times that a woman
might go through for instance postpartum
depression a special time of the month
and what are some other unique times and
challenges that a woman goes through so
how can a man deal because I it can be
overwhelming at times because the man is
also then we got a knowledge he's not
made he's made in a certain way you know
he's made to be like you know if the the
lion comes there in the jungle he's a
man he's not he's like and a woman wants
a man but also at the same time not some
person who's a tyrant so striking the
balance for him to be under to
understand her but it saves time her
being under understand how Allah made
him yes exactly
well as you said the woman needs someone
who is strong someone who is emotionally
by strong I mean also emotionally can
stand up and there and she she can trust
that you know he can look after the
family and protect them and so on the
woman would like for someone to for her
husband to to have a leadership and not
to really let things happen as it
happens but have a leadership and in the
right thing like leadership doesn't mean
here that he bosses people around when
the boss sees her around but in the same
time when things need to be decided he
can take that decision for example
sometimes you you mentioned something
about special time and special needs and
so on we know that many troubles and
many problems come from how the
relationship happened between the
different family
it's like what we call in-laws if say
for example a woman or a wife have some
misunderstanding or they don't really
communicate well herself and her
sister-in-law the leadership here will
be that the husband has to take a
position where he is fair and he can
communicate to both of them how
important each of his sister or his wife
to him and make some you know some sort
of a discussion or give some direction
for how they do that but sometimes some
men just let things happen and they
don't interfere at all and they don't
give any other interfere here doesn't
mean that you know he is going to but he
can mediate he can talk to his wife good
things about how he value her and then
the same time how it will make him so
happy that she makes it up with his
sister but then give her some direction
about what you know what she has to do
and what she doesn't have to do because
she's doing that to kiss him and do the
same thing with a sister so by this
mediation he is showing leadership and
that's some kind of strength that's
important in our time now as you said
the man is not made to to always have
that emotions and be very emotional but
when he feels his wife is she wants to
talk about it something that's bothering
her something that's bottled up in here
or she may not ask him that or tell him
that she wants to talk but she is not
herself she is quiet she is destined she
is that it will help so much that he
says are you upset about something
what's are you tired are you bothered
are you so she noticed or she feels that
he notice her mood also the woman's life
goes through cycles when once
she started to be a grown-up or like an
adult she goes through cycles and these
cycles happen because she is under the
effect of hormones that is going in
Psych and this of course is what needs
to be done for her as a woman so she can
bear children and give birth and so on
and the man has to notice that that
because she was on cycles then sometimes
these hormones are making air
oversensitive she could she could get
easily upset or or tired or and and
knowing that will help will help their
relationship that you know he in these
days he need to be more patient with her
and he need to realize that she may be
she gets tired so easily I remember
sometimes in you know conflicts between
a couple and it was it was resolved it
by the man noticing that yes this cycle
thing has an effect on her rather than
think she is lazy and she sleeps too
much for example so this is how you know
understanding the nature of each other
will help in a relationship rather than
just be judgemental and think someone is
lazy or someone doesn't have you know
enough heart to notice how she is and
and this kind of thoughts well before we
go to break what are your comments on I
had a a person who is also an expert in
this area
her name is a Doyle she wrote the book
called the surrendering wife are you
familiar with this book oh yeah you
haven't read it but are you heard about
it yes and she talks about the concept
between love and respect and really the
the
the drive for men more is the respect
that they desire more and the woman
desire more of the love but obviously
men want to be loved - but what's you
know the the water for the man because
we both need food and water but one we
need more than the other otherwise
you're gonna die if you if you don't
have water you know you can go longer
without food so that for the man is
respect for the woman it's the love what
are your comments on that yeah I believe
I believe I don't know if we take
respect as what's the implication of
respect if we take respect as sort of
you know do as I do as I asked of you or
do as you know as you know this is what
I like and so on yeah he might care more
about respect while if we acknowledge
that the woman needs to be nurtured with
love more then she also needs to be
respected because nobody likes anybody
nobody likes to be mess disrespected or
treated mistreated so I would say the
woman also likes to be respected but
it's not it's not a huge thing as long
as she is respected generally and we all
know when respect is at at least at the
level where it shouldn't go below then
yes she needs more love when I take a
break and we'll be right back with dr.
Acula I'm here on a Dean showed Oh
anywhere please subscribe to the video
follow us on our official Facebook and
Twitter pages in the links below
please also help support the V show by
making a donation in the link below back
here on the D show tell us can you tell
us now that a lot of times in
relationship there's certain things you
know that the man will do and then
sometimes certain things the woman will
do and does it really help when both
parties understand Billy it was a
book called men are from Mars Women from
Venus when we understand that Allah the
Creator the Almighty has made us
different we knowledge these differences
and but and then how can we get to to
the point where once we acknowledge
these differences that we can kind of
deal with each other in a better manner
yeah well once we acknowledge that we
are made different we're not going to be
shocked you know how did he do that to
me or how could she does this to me we
not we are learning about each other and
we acknowledge also that these
differences are for our own benefits and
for the benefits of the family and we
are open to learn about each other and
we must me like what I found that
sometimes when when between a couple
when thanks when they start you know in
the beginning of course everybody is
open and welcoming with the other person
and so on in the beginning of marriage
then when few things happen happens over
and over then many times they start to
be distant from each other because one
of them was trying to perhaps talk about
it and the other one took it lightly or
did not pay much attention to it so the
person who was who was feeling that they
not getting you know what they expected
from the marriage try to close up so
they don't get hurt more and they start
to be in a relationship yes they are
marriages they have their children but
they are not really feeling for each
other they are not communicating they
are not enjoying their life at all but
they just passing time and this is a
very serious situation that nobody
should allow it to happen to them how
could they do that they better refresh
from time to time they better get out
find somebody to take the kids if their
kids are young and
try to go out for go for a couple of
days if they can afford that if if they
you don't have anybody to believe their
kids with at least to go for a day go
for half a day and then they go back to
when they were just engaged or early
married and so on and the try to feel
for each other try to talk try to tell
it's it's as simple as it is but what
happened is that it becomes like a
mountain that they have to climb because
now they became distant and I would say
listening to each other is the most
important thing they can do and also
keep connect keep stay connected to the
Creator a lot panatela because when you
are connected to allah subhanaw taala
you receive everything with an open
heart but when you are not connected you
feel very harsh inside yourself and then
you are ready tense and the tension of
course is so high now in in everybody's
life and we have to have a way a healthy
way to de-stress and to let the
attention go so they are able to be
patient with each other they are able to
give and not not ask for you got to give
me back right away but you know just
wait a little bit and it's coming and in
addition to that I say people need to if
they feel they are in a situation where
they are not you know they're not
getting anywhere one of them is always
pushing their way his way or her way
then they need to let the other person
know and they need to tell them that
please we have to strike the balance in
the relationship and if they can't reach
that between the two of them alone there
is a rule and the Quran that say is that
he should invite someone from his side
and she should invite somebody from her
side and they they tell them the issue
and then they try to mediate between
them what I am saying here
is that they should not accept to live
together under the same roof as two
strangers they should try to work their
issues out and that there is different
ways they should handle it by themself
if they can't then they should reach out
for somebody to help mediate between
them if there is something that we won't
have a couple of minutes left if there's
just something in in one word in a
sentence some something key so a couple
key components something that you think
advice that you've given that really
helped you that you or you've gotten or
that you've given that's really helped
you know sometimes we can hear just one
sentence on a hadith and is something
that is so powerful that you can go back
to whenever you're in a dilemma is there
one of the something like that you can
share with us before we come to an end
okay well I'm going to say something
that's simple but it's not it's
different from hadith and yeah because
of course mashallah in the verses and in
the hadith and so on there is so much
guidance but I want to tell all
husband's that it's easy to please your
wife just acknowledge her feeling just
tell her that she is dear to you tell
her that you know yeah if it was you
know what she's upset that you don't
spend time with her or she's upset that
you know you she hasn't seen you for so
long or you are not sharing some just
ticket when you are around just to get
up and do what she is doing as we know
the prophet alayhi salat wa sallam
canopy monotony means which means that
he was always doing what his family is
doing what his wife is doing when you do
that you give her a lot of support and
it's not about how much you're going to
really finish in the little time that
you know you may share with her this
helping around the house but it's about
acknowledging that taking care of the
family at that level at the layer
of housekeeping and looking after the
children and so on is something valuable
it's not it's not like putting it down
and putting this kind of work that's
absolutely important and needed though
tell us where can people get some of
your you and your husband's books if
they're interested the books are printed
by a man a publication here in the
United States and I think it's a M en e
so a manna and you can look it up or
that's basically on Amazon or look a man
a publication itself and everything is
there yeah everything is there thank you
so much and thank you for tuning in to
the D show if you haven't subscribed
subscribe right now hope you got to
benefit from this advice we're here
every week with a new exciting show
until then peace be with you assalamu
alaikum please subscribe to the Biggio
follow us on our official Facebook and
Twitter pages in the links below
please also help support the D show by
making a donation in the link below